avec votre collègue de hacker luge de la
roque ce soldat de l'armée canadienne
qui a sauté sur une mine en afghanistan
il a dû se faire amputer la jambe c'est
arrivé à plusieurs militaires évidemment
158 morts on a parlé cette semaine que
vous nous ramenez une histoire cette
histoire de cet homme là qui remarque
heures oui en fait elles sont toutes
remarquables les histoires de ces
paralympiens me disais au moins a
raconté une qui va raconter un petit peu
le vécu de chacun de ces personnes là
parce que chacun sait pas aller bien
vécu d'abord saisir le deuil d'une
vision une perte d'un bras d'une jambe
d'une mobilité les chacun a vraiment
choisi la vie et c'est ça qui est
intéressant dans leur histoire c'est
humain et on a choisi de vous raconter
celle de dominique laroque pour tout ce
que vous venez de raconter mais aussi
parce que dimanche avec l'équipe
canadienne il va tenter de remporter la
médaille de bronze à aucun juge
dominique la route un symbole de
détermination des sporades pas une
grande importance
j'adore j'adore le challenge j'adore les
de l'intensité des vents dans le sport
de haut niveau football à l'école
secondaire hockey au niveau junior
dominique carbure au sport de
compétition c'est comme une drogue leçon
langues en plus convaincant
à 18 ans il cherche laventure et son
rôle dans les forces armées canadiennes
la raison pour laquelle je me suis
envolé c'était un beau rouge vient
d'avoir 18 ans de chanter un chant cas
d'école
sorti de chez nous
deux ans plus tard il est en afghanistan
depuis quatre mois kan lors d'une
opération militaire sa vie change pour
toujours
le véhicule dans lequel j'ai testé le
premier du convoi on était quatre
véhicules puis abandonnée sur la route
on a tout offert leur ressenti un peu un
peu comme un sixième sens et a senti
quelque chose de pas normal alors il
fait arrêter le convoi une fois catillon
tout sécurisé bay ont conduit ces beaux
voulu faire ramasser le le convoi puis
le véhicule à ce moment-là rouler sur un
terrain un engin improvisé qui a aidé
puis le véhicule exposé c'est moi que le
groupe de goodwood trois jours plus tard
à l'hôpital son réveil est brutal
puisque rares et où comme chaque écoute
un film je me souvenais pas que c'était
à moi c'était à louer de retour à québec
il commence sa réadaptation avec une
jambe artificielle sur les actrices ça
implique un certain temps avant de
l'accepter
on sait pas trouver qu'est ce qui va
devenir ce que je regarde de continuer à
travailler est-ce que je vais être
capable de dans votre copine un jour et
ce que je retiens d'avoir une vie
normale une fois que ça nous arrive ça
change ça change complètement je crois
que le côté poussé la chose la mieux
pour nous et pour toute notre entourage
c'est à ce moment qu'il voit pour la
première fois à la télé duo qui luge son
idée est faite il va jouer
en fait la fonction embarqué dans une
lutte j'étais comme un enfant
qui développe c'est qu'elle donnerait
puis quand je suis embarqué dans ma vie
je voulais être sur la glace de cours
juste bassiste alex commande si ça on
voit ce soir nîmes à chaque jour sara
tellement facile mais c'est
dominique s'investit totalement dans
l'apprentissage de sa nouvelle
discipline comme il le faisait avant son
accident et vend pas de différence entre
ce que les joueurs peuvent ressentir au
niveau joaquin normal ou en luge la
compétition et la main le sport reste la
même la rivalité on veut gagner
moins d'un an plus tard il perce la
formation de l'équipe nationale et
découvre une solidarité d'une intensité
un colis et moi je crois qu'ils ont
allié proche qui nous unit un peu plus
peut-être par les épreuves comptent
chacun repart c'est con ça commence pour
sa qualité j'espère maintenant aux
paralympiques de sotchi dominique peu
mieux embrasser le destin qui est le
sien
on a déjà posé la question de penser
préféré dessus récupère et agents
avoir une ce que tu as vécu cinq fûts la
question est assez passive a prévenu
l'expert image en mai
je regarde pour